[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue à uriner versailles
donc on va vous expliquer comment on
transforme le colza fraîchement récoltés
en huile et en tourteaux venez
[Musique]
la première étape qu'on reçoit le colza
une fois qu'il ait pesé sur le déversent
dans une fosse donc c'est un trou où
tout le colza est évident est comme ça
le roman peut repartir à la moisson au
chant le colza passe alors dans cette
machine où on enlève tout ce qui importe
est grossière et légère là on obtient un
exemple de de déchets issus de la
récolte donc tout cela est valorisable
méthanisation pour faire du gaz et de
l'engrais naturel
voici la presse donc ici de calais
graines de colza
nettoyez qui arrive
elles descendent et l'impasse dans une
vis sans fin hop
finalement la graine de colza est
écrasée de décoter ou à l'huile qui soit
et à l'autre bout on voit le topo de
coûts totaux ces foires c'est tout ce
qui est pas huile de colza la graine de
soja récit riche en protéines c'est la
base de l'alimentation animale
[Musique]
il ne faudra après stockés dans ces
grandes cuves que vous voyez au fond et
donc lui les filtrer et misant une cuvée
après entre chaque cuve c'est des
qualités différentes suivant les
débouchés nos principaux débouchés donc
c'est une huile le co génération donc
c'est pour fabriquer électricité et
chaleur et donc je fournis donc de
l'huile de colza en tant que combustible
pour des bâtiments énergie positive sur
paris
[Musique]
je
et voilà donc on retrouve notre huile de
colza version alimentaire donc on
s'incline donc plutôt point restauration
collective en de l'idpe la restauration
collective on les individuels puisque
format pratique conviviale et le
meilleur rapport qualité prix est
également en bouteille en verre en 50
centilitres
[Musique]